Darcy is with us hey Darcy how are you
I'm glad how are you mr. Ramsey right
I'm better than I deserve what's up so I
am graduating college next week yeah
finance yeah you got your job yet yes
I've been counting job lined up so what
are you gonna be making I'll be making
46 years 26,000 years benefit bonus how
about strong then that gets your foot in
the door there we go
good for you well played thank you and
well I'll be graduating debt-free and I
just paid off my car and everything so I
have no debt right now and I was just
wondering I have like enough
I got like 25 saved up from a mortgage
or a house and I live with my mom right
now just so I can save money and that's
what I've been doing so I could pay off
school and I just wanted to know I was
watching some of your shows where you
say like it shouldn't live with their
parents but I don't know what to do
after this I guess is what my question
is yeah well here's the thing kids never
live with their parents is not what I
say Tish TP teach people that your
parents home should be a safety net not
a hammock yeah okay
and so how old are you I'm 22 yeah so if
you're still hanging out there when
you're 32 we're going to call you up and
smack you around a little bit okay but
if you're unless there's a real health
problem or some kind of issue right
but I mean if you're just too lazy to
leave then you know any any eagle that
doesn't leave the nest eventually it's
called a turkey and so you know we have
to think this through so our do you have
to panic and leave home by Dave Ramsey
standards in the next 20 minutes no my
22 year old daughter my oldest one moved
home with us after she graduated and got
a good job and it was not for financial
reasons it just took a little while to
get settled in and so she lived with us
for about four months after she
graduated
and then she went and got an apartment
with some friends and it helped her to
go get that apartment so I I would tell
you this I I'm not on fire about this
thing I just try to keep people from
hanging out for the wrong reasons and
really using your mom as a crutch to
save more money only should be a
temporary thing okay so I would say if I
were in your mom's shoes I would want
you gone by Christmas okay 70 cents and
it's still a good idea to get a house
around here is that right or should I
rent because you couldn't you can rent
for a little while if you want to and
save up more money and then get your
house there's no sin in renting for a
couple of years again I don't want you
waking up at 40 to still renting because
you couldn't get your financial act
together but renting for a little while
as a time to get settled in get used to
paying bills playing all the adult games
that we play now all this kind of stuff
I got to write the Alaia and I got to
make sure the web is connected to my
electricity so it doesn't cut off and
all that stuff you got to do to just
live life you know I got to buy
groceries or there's not any that kind
of stuff
nothing's done for you in other words
all that kind of thing and just getting
all that settled is okay and then buy a
house in a year or two or you know
something like that but there's no panic
like Oh for a year if you rent for a
year it's not I mean you're 22 got
plenty of time that's kind of what goes
in my head though just because like
reading everything and it's not equity
so I feel like I'm just kind of dumping
in there nothing it's normal when I was
22 I was in such a hurry yeah it's
normal to be in a hurry and all I'm
saying is if you'll go a little bit
slower you'll actually get there faster
that's all I'm saying yeah you got it
you're doing great you're graduating
debt-free you're already saved money you
got a job you got a degree in something
that's actually freaking useable you
just are a rockstar all the way around I
mean you're a home run kiddo
I appreciate getting to talk to you
absolutely amazing very very cool stuff